you know I am so tempted to just say
look it's like 30 seconds worth of stuff
what do you want from me but yeah almost
eight minutes talking about the logo so
let's try doctor who has released a
teaser for series 11 and despite the
fact that I'm supposed to be on vacation
I guess I'm going to talk about it
supposedly we're still getting um was
something closer to a full trailer at
San Diego comic-con
I will actually legitimately be on
vacation as in physically away from here
when that happens so any video on that
is gonna be a couple days later but yeah
so let me think there just think that
there's very little to this there's
about as much to this as there was to
like the a my good man teasers you know
ahead of a head of Capaldi stuff you
know where is he's just shots of him
standing there and the tart is blowing
up and it doesn't mean anything so I
don't think that there's very much to
actually be taken away from this from
these images from any of it my big
takeaway the one thing that I can say
that I noticed
I don't like which is oh all three
companions are from the modern day UK
great because we haven't seen that every
single friggin series look I've
complained about the the companion
template before and while I do
appreciate that two of them are male and
one of them is significantly older than
a standard we've got three you couldn't
even have one from the past from the
future from a space station something
other than modern earth
and the sort of the gimmick of oh it's
like the pizza regenerated and here's
this old-timey magazine and what
actually happens with that first thing
like III I did I didn't think much of it
but then my my lifelong nemesis of the
past three years or so irredeemable shag
he actually asked me what actually
happens there and ivory washed it like
four times and I don't know he's like
watching about a football game and
there's a flash and he dips I don't know
what he dips I think he gives a fry into
mustard I suppose it could be a fish
finger of the custard I don't know and
then he kind of looks around but like
what changed like it's really blatant in
the other sections you know we see empty
pizza box Oh complete pizza you know we
get you know you see his newspaper Oh
old timey magazine hmm what happened
with that first guy I can't I can't
figure it out I tried to hear if maybe
something went weird with the broadcast
and his and his football team or squad
or whatever you folks call them over
there but all three of them seem to be
watching that same broadcast and it
seems consistent all the way through so
I could figure out what the heck even
happens in that one
I still like Whitaker smile I like what
occurs smile a lot and I might be
latching on to this possibly
disproportionately because one of the
things I really liked about her initial
you know a few seconds that she got at
the end of twice upon a time I'm I still
like to you know hear more than two
words out of her mouth at some point
that would be nice
there's if I'm really going to like dig
into this there's a certain sense of
adventure to this optimistic adventure
it seems to be the vibe of this and even
the
line the universe is calling seems to be
like come on with us you know join us on
this trip let's have some fun which is
what I was hoping for because you know
looking I'll get to more of this later
on as you see the videos on broadchurch
but you know haven't gotten a better
sense of what Chibnall is good at and
how that may or may not get applied to
Doctor Who it's reassuring to me to see
a what at least what appears to be a
kind of lighter tone you know the
doctors smiling the companions aren't in
danger they're intrigued it's it's not a
you know am i a good man deep heavy
things blowing up you know I say that
and I even like Capaldi's time and the
TARDIS for the most part but it is
here's this character who seems to have
some weirdness going on about them seems
to be having fun let's go see what that
is and I I I appreciate that vibe I
appreciate that feel I would have been
really nervous if there have been a real
dark and ominous vibe to this trailer
because you know that's not I'm not idea
I do appreciate when Doctor Who goes
dark on an episode by episode basis I
don't want the show to become that as a
general vibe and the general vibe I got
off this is very much what I want I'm
still really annoyed at the companions
you know feeling like I've now confirmed
all three from modern day era UK so but
those are kind of my two big takeaways
annoyance at that confusion over I guess
three big takeaways confusion over what
the heck happened with that first guy
and light-touch vibe and I am down for
that and I will be really curious to see
what we get from comic-con assuming that
you know it
still happen and/or it doesn't leak
earlier you know who knows what happens
but assuming that that is more of a
full-on proper trailer and like we'll
get footage safe from the actual
episodes and maybe get some dialogue
from her and get a better sense of this
doctor but I like that so far the
recurring image in the most prominent
image I have of Jodie Whittaker as the
doctor is smiling I take comfort in that
again I I did enjoy Capaldi and probably
could be very cranky but I'm looking
forward to that sense of adventure and
fun and not just in the show but in the
doctor as a character
going out and seeking adventure not
necessarily seeking problems but seeking
adventure and again I fully omit this is
me extrapolating putting way too much
weight on like it's a 50 second video
but it's effectively 30 seconds worth of
anything really but you know if I'm
gonna overanalyze I'm gonna over there
analyze them when I overanalyze the
logistical details about the companion
zone or me the general feel and vibe
gives me a good feeling and is
encouraging so I think that's about all
I've got I don't know if I it would be
better seeing if I managed to get less
out of the teaser than I did out of
analyzing the logo ah don't know Oh on a
completely unrelated know in case
anybody else asked yes I am aware that
Scarlett Johansson dropped out of
rub-and-tug and is no longer playing
Dante Gill the trans man character I do
know that that happened I'm not planning
to do a follow-up video because look I'm
stopping and we in the middle of my
vacation real quick to do this I'm going
back on my vacation but by the time I'm
back that is very much old news unless
there's some kind of new development in
that ie we the project is still moving
forward and they have somebody else cast
it's short of something like that I I
don't have enough to say about it I
still feel the same
than initial casting that I always did
so there you go so that was completely
unrelated unnecessary but probably got
me over the time so I spent longer
talking about this then about the logo
so I'll take it so those are my thoughts
on the teaser for series 11 I love
Doctor Who I'm assuming you've seen it
didn't take you very long to get through
it no reason you shouldn't have what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts aren't drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a ton of stuff to do not gonna bog you
down with it patrons the big one I'll
admit to that but links for everything
is down in the description and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]